anne elisabeth lemoine irait hier elle
recevait sur le plateau de c'est à vous
le groupe ntm
le problème c'est que les invités ont
voulu marquer le coup en lui offrant une
bouteille de rhum et regarder eh ben
elle en a bu alors ces ricains il ya des
gens sur twitter qui ont dit oui
et dire qu'on paye une redevance à
sézanne qui en plus manger à nos frais
choqué par le comportement de ma bête
lemoine boire de l'alcool sur le service
public c'est n'importe quoi
je paye pour ça moi hashtag revanche
voilà ce qu'elle me voilà les sur les
trucs que j'ai vu passer
regardez la séquence pour une
consommation personnelle
c'est pour nous tous c'est toujours un
plaisir
[Musique]
comment cdt tôt les meilleurs d'accord
elle avait fini par y alors qu'est ce
que vous avancez
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
été choqués par cette séquence
jean-michel qu'est ce t'en pense même
qu'avec avoue thème pas si vous m'y
autorise et j'aurai le plus parlé
jusqu'à ce que je tombe parce que tu
dises reste très peu d'énergie
j'essaie d'oublier mais donne alors j'ai
dit non non les crampes sous la voûte
plantaire
c'est horrible je suis d'accord moi tout
ce qui rompt un peu là les codes et qui
auront revient sur un peu d'humanité et
qu'on a un coût dont gaza pour débloquer
des gens qui étaient choqués gilles
merlet pour ses rangs franchement cyril
moi je suis très choqué je fais ma
brigade est donné à 20 ans tu vas payer
aussi moi je veux dire imaginons que la
scène se soit passé sur ce vélo nage et
de boucliers qu'il a raison ils ont la
carte
il n'y a pas de levée de boucliers mais
moi personnellement j'ai été choqué je
suis d'accord en plus je vous dis j'aime
beaucoup un leader est on est on est
très potes et même avec son producteur
pierre antoine capton que j'aime
beaucoup mais mêmes lui je suis sûr
qu'il est d'accord avec nous si ça
c'était passé oui ce plateau et pour on
ne fait pas un bateau sans rigoler pour
cole fait pas mal non
[Applaudissements]
la raison je vous rappelle que l'alcool
est dangereux pour la santé
mais les deux hommes je suis d'accord
année benhaim va boire un petit coup de
vous êtes d'accord entre 2000 et 2001
s'il vous plaît parce que vous l'avez
valérie ce n'est pas ça mais justement
vous allez c'est vous qui avait levé le
lever le voile sur ce problème
si ça s'était passé sur ce plateau
ç'aurait été un drame oui j'aimerais
qu'on fasse la même chose
valérie bénaïm voilà je suis just a en
plus avec on est comme ça tous les jeux
vous propose de boire un verre chez moi
je l'aimé tellement
c'est rien du tout comme ça voilà
valérie et on va voir si nous jusqu'en
bien des répercussions si nous en train
etc
[Applaudissements]
la série de ses parents c'est pas bon de
faire sacrément reste que si on le fait
ils vont dire on punit passé huit ans
punit pas france 5 on ne fait pas on les
laisse tout seul voir ce qu'elle sait ça
ils vont dire moi j'ai pas envie que son
récent faux pas montré de l'alcool à la
télé les enfants inertes et il est c'est
bon on peut voir cyril on tombe tous et
on fait une chaîne d'alcoolique
[Rires]
ouais je sais vous plaît je vais vous
dire juste un truc là dessus bien sûr
l'alcool est dangereux pour la santé
c'est pas bien de faire ça tout ça mais
moi j'ai pas envie que france 5 connu
une sanction parce que maintenant je les
adore et moi j'aime pas bien oui
pourquoi ils ont réussi ont fait ça moi
je pense que personne doit prendre de
sanction parce que j'ai mal à tenir
c'est les trucs voilà qu'ils sont at war
ban a un empêchement séquence hilarante
anne-elisabeth procès on la reconnaît et
salue comme ça allait droite elle est
bien y'a pas de problème avec aise avec
voilà les chéris elle était avec mtn
elle s'est laissée sans voix là elle
s'est laissée emporter par là puis voilà
si la merci à une sanction du csa la
scion avoir l'air mais sans le sou pour
nous avec sanction pour ben haim qui va
bien tu risques bien est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un d'intelligent surtout un truc
pareil cas ce sera bien la première fois
dans la rue mission encore une fois les
téléspectateurs ce qui nous regarde ne
sont pas des bébés la télévision n'a pas
valeur d'exemple et les gens connus
n'ont pas valeur d'exemple
oui agent je me suis arrêté dans la voie
des bus par hasard que j'ai fait et le
tibet dit vous êtes tenus vous devrez
est un exemple non je suis comme tout le
monde c'est les mêmes conneries les
mêmes bêtises pourrait trouver des noms
la télévision a n'a pas valeur d'exemple
non plus c'est pas parce qu'ils ont vu à
la télévision qu'ils ont choqué la
france entière et que les gens de voir
grandir c'est mal les gens qui
regardaient la télé sent bien que la non
pas les mauvais non non non non là je
suis pas d'accord avec vous parce qu'il
ya des gens qui disent regarde il vous
dira même le à la télé il faut bien sûr
la friperie dis pas de bêtises alors
c'est vous la sujet des grosses bettié
c'est bien marrant je t'aime beaucoup
mais il est chaud qui regarde après vont
prendre l'exemple et bat en radiant na
l'a fait à la télé anne elisabeth
lemoine ntm l'ont fait pourquoi on
boirait pas nous avec des potes à
liverpool après avoir fait des défis à
la presse a fait des défis à la con tout
ça danse eric pardon le concept de cette
émission était trop piquant de manger de
bois ils sont déjà les verres remplis de
20 l omerta calmette à sa bouche est au
cours d'un repas par exemple dans
l'émission le csa ferme les yeux
lorsqu'il a des verres remplis qu'il n'y
a pas la promotion de l'alcool et qu'on
ne les montre pas en train de de boire
et de promouvoir l'alcool est exagéré ce
niveau là même si normalement il devrait
pas y en avoir du tout alors oui jean
michel donc la télé c'est plus le reflet
de leroy les biens des familles et toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la télé c'était le reflet de la vie la
société a bientôt on pourra plus péter
o'toole plateau non plus on peut boire
un coup c'est pas dramatique là on peut
boire un coup sa voix là bas côtés alors
rangé dans le camp des ayatollahs si
vous aussi vous nous regardez dans ce
cas là alors on a quoi on pète toutes
les règles en télévision qu'on diffuse
les tontons flagueurs il se bourrer la
gueule personne m'a picoler après
l'office la télévision c'est la réalité
1300 on en direct à rationner le jeu
s'est passée la chaîne de caractères que
du coup il nous diffuse des aquariums
pour nous dire venez de l'eau alors on
va voir ce qu'on pense et
téléspectateurs à laguiole
j'aime 65 pas là et le français bois
[Applaudissements]
l'animal attend toujours son petit verre
[Rires]
c'est ça votre poêle à bois hibon soir
merci c'est chaud c'est du whisky si nos
albums valbuena alors il fait le
contraire va là bas dit alban petit moi
je m'en fous un mondial et ça c'est mon
quotidien dégâts sur les poteaux ya un
gars qui bossent qu'est ce qui se passe
je propose qu'on fasse acquis doucet
tout public tout ça tous les tous bords
aux normes de rejet
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la ruine cette émission ou picholine ça
fait une heure et demi qu'on est sur le
point sur les poteaux la paroisse une
goutte d'eau c'est koh lanta jusqu'aux
genoux et tu crois tu crois que ça
allait